lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
introducir la noción de una función de
consumo de hecho la idea es muy
sencillita simplemente nos dice que si
en una economía tenemos ingresos ingreso
agregado entonces eso causa consumo
consumo agregado
entonces consumo y navas para aclarar un
poco las cosas y hacerlas un poco más
concretas ahorita voy a construir una
función de consumo para una economía
hipotética después podemos debatir si
podemos hacer una mejor o sean estos
números que voy a poner no tienen que
ser exactos pero esto nada más es para
hacer las cosas concretas vale entonces
a lo mejor en una economía hipotética el
consumo va a ser igual
y a lo mejor hay un nivel base de
consumo verdad aunque no haya ingreso
agregado lo cual es difícil de pensar
pero bueno suponiendo que no lo hay de
todas formas la gente va a estar algo
base para eso va a tener que buscar en
sus ahorros verdad va a tener que
gastarse lo que ya acumuló bueno digamos
que para esta economía el nivel base de
consumo es 500 500 capers no sé de 500
miles de millones de pesos o monedas de
oro o no sé piezas de chocolate lo que
sea que sea la moneda en nuestra
economía
esto de aquí es base verdad el nivel
base y luego supongamos que si hay algo
de ingreso agregado entonces las
personas se van a gastar 60% de eso otra
vez estoy eligiendo números aleatorios
entonces digamos que después de este
nivel va se van a gastar 0.6 de
cualquier ingreso adicional que tengan
hecho aparecer un poco más específico
debes de escribir ingresos voy a
escribir ingreso disponible lo pongo con
otro color ingreso sin eso no es otro
color entonces van después del nivel
base van a gastar 60 por ciento de su
ingreso disponible ingreso disponible y
estoy haciendo esta distinción verdad
estoy haciendo esta aclaración entre
ingreso y ingreso disponible porque pues
todo el ingreso agregado en la economía
no acaba en los bolsillos de los
consumidores llego a lo mejor podría
decir bueno las personas se lo pagan a
empresas pero finalmente las empresas
tienen unos dueños que también son
consumidores más bien a lo que ahorita
me estoy refiriendo es que parte de ese
dinero acaba en el bolsillo del gobierno
acaba pagado en forma de impuestos le
pongo aquí ingresos y si has visto
muchos
de pago a lo mejor te has dado cuenta
que no todo lo que ganas es para ti no
todo acaba en tu bolsillo o no acaba en
tu cuenta de cheques una buena parte de
esos impuestos que acabas pagando celos
al gobierno y lo que queda después de
restar esos impuestos a eso es algo que
yo llamo el ingreso disponible preso
disponible y por eso escribí aquí
ingreso disponible porque esto es un
poco más razonable verdad que la gente
gaste 60 por ciento de su ingreso
disponible sino de todo el ingreso por
que gastarían un poco de los impuestos
pero los impuestos ya los pagaron y pues
para visualizar esto lo que vamos a
hacer es dibujar una línea vale a lo
mejor esto te recuerda tus épocas de
álgebra vamos a tener un par de ejes en
vez de tener una variable ya tenemos una
variable ce que es la variable
dependiente en función de ingreso
disponible usualmente esto de aquí se le
llama x pero pues igual se puede llamar
ingreso disponible y ser la variable
independiente dejada pongo los ejes un
poco más bonitos para dibujar nuestra
pues esencialmente va a quedar una línea
digo no todas las funciones de consumo
tienen por qué quedar como una línea
pero así nos quedó ahorita por el modelo
entonces este de aquí es
déjalo como por acá está aquí es el eje
vertical verdad ya sabes billones de
pesos quizás de chocolate lo que quieras
aquí tenemos ingresos disponibles
ingreso
disponible
y entonces si hay cero de ingreso
disponible deja hago la tabla
entonces si tenemos cero ingreso
disponible que le voy a poner consumo
entonces si hay cero en ingreso
disponible estoy acá se hace cero y el
consumo simplemente es la base que es
500 millones de lo que sea entonces el
consumo es 500 va la coordenada sería
dejarlo como en el plano es aquí verdad
es el 0 500 en la línea horizontal no te
mueves nada porque es 0 y en el eje
vertical es 500 500 y digamos ahora que
el ingreso disponible es no sé vamos a
poner mil mil mil millones de lo que sea
entonces aquí está el mil mil millones
de piezas de chocolate lo que sea ya no
quiero repetir la unidad bueno mil
1000 entonces el consumo cuánto sería
pues vamos a la formulita el consumo
sería igual al consumo base 500 más 0.6
x 1000 entonces es 500 más 610 mil 100
ok entonces vamos al puntito aquí
tenemos el 1.000 1.100 y entonces el
puntito aquí en el plano sería 1000 aquí
sería como mil aquí es como 1100 sería
como por aquí verdad este punto de acá
sería el punto con coordenadas mil coma
1100 ok y como te decía estoy aquí queda
una línea no tiene por qué quedar así
después veremos modelos más complicados
pero entonces en este caso en este caso
particular la función de consumo se
vería algo así más o menos así verdad ya
tenemos dos puntos si te acuerdas un
poco de álgebra puedes ver a esto como
la intersección en el eje bueno en este
caso el eje y la pendiente es de 0.6
después vamos a practicar un poquito qué
tiene que ver la pendiente con la
propensión marginal al consumo pero
bueno ahorita lo que quiero comentar es
que es una idea muy sencilla claro la
función de consumo no tiene
que verse así aunque las funciones del
consumo que se estudian en los cursos
básicos de economía sean de este estilo
con un consumo base y con una propensión
marginal el consumo en realidad uno
podría argumentar cosas muy distintas
verdad en realidad no sé la función de
consumo podría verse así a lo mejor
cuando el ingreso es bajo para cada peso
adicional de ingreso la gente va a estar
dispuesta a pagar mucho más y luego
cuando empiezan a tener un ingreso más y
más alto entonces van a gastar una menor
y menor parte de su ingreso disponible
más o menos lo que estoy diciendo es que
la propensión marginal al consumo cambia
en el primer modelo era algo muy
sencillo verdad la propensión marginal
al consumo era una constante para
cualquier peso adicional gastaba 60
centavos siempre no importa qué tan rico
fueras era de 0.6 todo el tiempo deja lo
pongo aquí propensión marginal al
consumo pero a lo mejor hay un modelo
más complejo verdad a lo mejor pues no
se puede tener una propensión marginal a
el consumo muy alta cuando tienes
poquito dinero porque quieres aumentar
rápidamente tu estándar de vida verdad y
luego si eres más y más rico entonces ya
tienes una buena calidad
y vas a decir pues mejor voy a ahorrar
un poquito de dinero para cualquier
imprevisto